ja und jörg paczkowski ist auch
stellvertretender parteichef hier heißt
das stellt heute in der bundessprecher
der afg husky alexander gauland hat
heute in seiner rede ist er ganz klar
auf konfrontationskurs gegangen das
klang auch alles ziemlich unversöhnlich
gesagt hat wird mit einem solchen mit
einer solchen einstellung mit einer
solchen einrichtung wird die partei aber
schlecht anschlussfähig für koalitionen
die sie ja eigentlich befürworten
zunächst mal muss man sagen dass das ein
parteitag ist und natürlich muss auf dem
parteitag eine kämpferische rede
gehalten werden das hat glaube ich
alexander gauland sehr deutlich gemacht
er hat sicherlich auch deutlich gemacht
dass es die afg nicht zum nulltarif gibt
und ich denke damit hat er auch das
richtige zeichen für den parteitag
gesetzt weil viele dinge die ihr gesagt
hat die sind ja doch waren und ich denke
dass wir damit auch ein klares zeichen
gegen der cdu und csu umgesetzt haben
dass die ihr half die auch ihre politik
weiter verfolgen wird
es sollten viele vergleich mit 1989 in
der ddr gezogen sind sie berliner waren
die korrekt können sie das so
unterschreiben
man kann zumindest parallelen
feststellen ich komme ja auch ich bin ja
nun der einzige landesverband oder der
chef des einzigen landesverbandes der
sowohl west als auch ost hat und je
öfter ich in den osten komme höre ich
eben dass viele menschen sagen ja wir
haben das gefühl es ist wie 1989
und ich denke das ist auch der auslöser
gewesen warum alexander gauland dieser
vergleiche gezogen hat man kann
parallelen feststellen und ich denke
dass es durchaus legitim das zu tun hat
sich die parteien den letzten monaten
radikalisiert nein die partei hat sich
nicht radikalisiert ich denke eher dass
die partei auch natürlich durch den
erfolg den sie hat auch natürlich durch
ich sag mal die bundestagsfraktion der
idee da ist mehr in den mittelpunkt
geschoben und wird jetzt auch ganz
anders wahrgenommen als das
möglicherweise noch vor einem jahr der
fall war aber radikalität kann ich in
der partei nicht verstellen
das stichwort ist bundestagsfraktion
durch das auftreten der
bundestagsfraktion der afd scheinen sich
ja die parteipolitischen gräben dort
vertieft zu haben und hat sogar das
gefühl dass ich die anderen dass es
unter den anderen fraktionen eine art
des solidarisierungseffekt gibt war das
beabsichtigt wir haben dass das phänomen
in allen landtagen auch also ich habe
das in berlin im abgeordnetenhaus in
ähnlicher weise wenn die afg in das
parlament kommt findet zunächst mal
einen solidarisierungseffekt bei den
anderen parteien statt
und dann ist es wichtig dass tatsächlich
überzeugungsarbeit geleistet wird
überzeugungsarbeit dahingehend dass man
gute arbeit abliefert dass man konzepte
arbeitet vorstellen dass man seriöse
politische arbeit macht und wir merken
dass sie in dem einen oder anderen
landtag das durchaus auch das gespräch
gesucht wird und dass einzelne natürlich
auch gezielt das gespräch mit mir
beispielsweise suchen
das zeigt wir wir sind noch nicht
normalität aber es geht langsam in
trippelschritten zur normalität in meine
frage war ja umgekehrt dass das
auftreten der afg erst diese
solidarisierungseffekt bei den anderen
erzeugt natürlich ist das auftreten der
dfb auch oder hat dazu geführt dass hier
solidarität stattfindet weil die afg
sein und ins parlament gekommen und sie
hat bestimmte abgeordnete aus dem
parlament verdrängt und die afg zunächst
mal ein fremd faktor in den in den
parlamenten aber die anderen parteien
werden sich daran gewöhnen müssen dass
die fdp da ist dass die afg bleibt dass
die fdp politik macht und irgendwann
wird man nicht umhin kommen auch mit der
afg zusammenzuarbeiten und wir haben das
teilweise in den landtagen schon dass
bei einzelnen anträgen mit der fdp
abgestimmt wird und das ist eigentlich
ein zeichen dass wir in der
parlamentarischen demokratie
ja ich sag mal nicht nur angekommen sind
sondern dass wir auch er hat zumindest
ich sage mal akzente setzen in vielen
bereichen wirkt die fdp noch wie ein
newcomer partei nützt es der partei
jetzt dass es sich vielleicht in
nächster zeit auch auf zum teil
kontroverse sachthemen konzentriert zum
beispiel die frage der
rentenversicherung und des rentensystems
in deutschland oder auch der
parteistiftung die heute noch diskutiert
wird
das war von anfang an eigentlich mein
ziel auch gewesen
wir können nicht nur
an die politik machen sondern wir müssen
auch mit tragfähigen konzepten kommen um
seriös wahrgenommen zu werden muss die
fdp liefern und wir sind jetzt dabei zu
liefern wir haben uns so weit
konsolidiert dass wir jetzt auch viele
fachleute haben dass wir bundes
fachausschüsse haben wir haben die
bundesprogramm kommission landes
fachausschüsse und in diesem wird sehr
sehr gut gearbeitet und die afg zeigt
jetzt dass sie eben nicht nur die partei
ist die die stimme erhebt wenn die
anderen was falsch machen sondern dass
sie auch tragfähige konzepte erarbeiten
kann
gerade beim thema rentenpolitik scheint
es sich hat zu zeigen dass es einen riss
durch die afg gibt zwischen west und ost
landesverbänden sogar darauf hingewiesen
dass sie der einzige landesverband sind
wo beide ost und west enthalten sind
besteht dann die gefahr dass es ihren
landesverband wegen dieser frage
vielleicht nicht zerreißt aber doch
schwer belastet nein meines erachtens
nicht denn wir sind jetzt an einem punkt
wo tatsächlich renten konzepte
ausgearbeitet worden sind ich denke
morgen hat heute früh auch eine eine
gute rede gehalten zum thema rente war
er hat mal die ganzen probleme
aufgezeigt und jetzt geht es darum
wirklich eine tragfähige und eine
zukunftsfähige lösung im bereich hände
zu finden
das wird weder der paternalistische
ansatz sei noch noch wird das der ganz
liberaler ansatz sein
ich gehe davon aus es wird irgendwo eine
möglichkeit sein dass man tatsächlich
ein tragfähiges rentenkonzept findet das
auch über viele jahre durchaus ich sag
mal valide sein kann
sie stehen in der partei für
pragmatismus auch für
lösungsorientierung ich nehme an dass
sie für die einrichtung einer partei
stiftung sind ja ich bin für die
einrichtung einer parteistiftung weil es
geht uns gar nicht so sehr um die um die
öffentlichen gelder sondern es geht uns
einfach darum parteistiftung leisten
wichtige arbeit für die parteien
das sind beispielsweise die außen- oder
ist beispielsweise die ausbildung von
kommunalpolitikern das ist
beispielsweise politische weiterbildung
das sind beispielsweise die vergabe von
stipendien und diese aufgaben müssen
wahrgenommen werden und ich als berliner
vorsitzen habe gemerkt wie schwer es ist
nach dem wir in die
bezirksverordnetenversammlung gekommen
sind die kommunalpolitiker auszubilden
und dafür braucht man eine stiftung
soweit gestellt hatte in der
bundesspitze der afg und berliner
landesvorsitzender
herzlichen dank für das gespräch wenn
sie vielleicht hinter mir vorbei gegen
diese zuschauer sicher machen jetzt
einen art afg staffellauf es gibt
nämlich gleich einen weiteren politiker
der sehen sie jetzt gerade hinter uns
sich mit herz der ski noch abspricht
aber er ist natürlich für das phoenix
interview daran hatte der
landesvorsitzende von thüringen
sie haben gerade zum thema rentenkonzept
gesprochen darf stehen sie ja für eine
ganz bestimmte position auch bei der afd
sie haben gesagt da müsse man identität
und solidarität verbinden was meinen sie
genau mit dieser verbindung gerade im
bereich der sozialpolitik
na gut das es vor allen dingen mal die
erkenntnis dass ein sozialstaat nur eine
zukunft haben kann wenn er eine wand
oder in einem land praktiziert wird das
auch geschlossene grenzen hat das sein
was er im augenblick erleben durch die
illegale einwanderungspolitik der
altparteien ist dass unser sozialstaat
zur plünderung freigegeben wird und das
kann nicht sein
wir müssen einfach wieder zu der
normalen politik aus richtung kommen
dass der wohlstand der in diesem lande
erarbeitet wird in erster linie auch
denen zu guten korb zu gute kommt die
ihn erarbeitet haben und das gilt auch
für die sozialpolitik das heißt
plünderung des sozialstaates gut jetzt
müssen flüchtigen die hierher kommen die
ja zunächst mal asylverfahren
durchlaufen auch versorgt hatten ist das
schon plünderung des sozialstaats ja
schauen sie sich doch mal die zahlen an
wenn wir mal uns vor augen halten dass
wir 2010 im sogenannten hat vier system
etwa 18 prozent menschen mit migrations
mit ausländischer staatsangehörigkeit
haben und dass er jetzt mittlerweile
anfang 2018 sind nicht bezahle ich kenne
anfang 2018 über 33% menschen ohne
deutsche staatsangehörigkeit im
hartz-iv-system haben dann erkennen wir
eine signifikante zunahme die letztlich
auf eine einwanderung zurückzuführen ist
die nicht nur illegal ist dass es
jedenfalls unsere fest überzeugen
sondern unser land vor allen dingen
nichts nützt und das muss ein ende haben
die rechtslage ist ja da eindeutig wer
in die rentenversicherung einzahlt
bekommt auch leistungen die
anwartschaften das stellen sie aber
nicht in frage
nein da stellen wir nicht in frage wir
haben vor kurzem auch ein thüringerin
konzept veröffentlicht dass diese frage
auch noch einmal aufgreift wer einzahlt
muss auch ansprüche an sammeln können
und die am ende dann ausgezahlt bekommt
aber wir wollen ganz gerne eine
staatsbürger rente etablieren das heißt
wir wollen einen deutlichen unterschied
zwischen der grundversorgung und dann im
rentenniveau auch für die wir aus
welchen gründen auch immer gebrochene
biographien usw
es gibt zahlreiche gründe nicht dienen
die vollen beitragssatz zusammen sammeln
konnte sie haben die afg gerade als
partei des sozialen friedens bezeichnet
ist das nicht ein etwas verengung dieses
begriffs sozialer frieden denn zum
sozialen frieden insgesamt gehört ja
auch ein gesamtgesellschaftlicher
ausgleichen dem alle konflikte auch
eingebunden sind und die dann auch
irgendwann mal gelöst werden müssen
ja das ist vollkommen richtig die partei
meine partei ist die partei der sozialen
gerechtigkeit und des sozialen friedens
weil das ergebnis der politik der
letzten jahre ist wie ich das schon aus
führte die auflösung unseres
sozialstaates und eine gesellschaft die
keinen sozialen frieden mehr hat hat
auch keinen wirtschaftlichen erfolg
langfristig mehr
deswegen müssen wir dieses thema auf die
politische agenda nehmen und zwar ganz
oben
auflösung des sozialstaates die renten
werden jeden monat ausbezahlt es gibt
ein gesundheitssystem das zwar menge hat
aber gegenüber vielen anderen systemen
doch sehr vorbildlich gibt es gibt eine
arbeitslosenversicherung es gibt eine
pflegeversicherung die zwar
reformbedürftig ist aber das ist doch
keine auflösung des sozialstaats
ich habe die zahlen für die für das
system schon glaube ich genügend
referiert könnt jetzt andere bereiche
nehmen wo deutlich wird dass wir eine
millionenfache zuwanderung in den
letzten jahren zugelassen haben die uns
nichts nützt sondern die sozialsysteme
maximal belastet die einwanderung der
letzten jahre ist nicht regelmäßig in
den arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren vor
allen dingen ist es eine einwanderung
die über das asyl ticket diesen dann
zugeführt wird wir haben also noch nicht
mal ein wirkliches einwanderungsgesetz
auch da müssen wir ran
werden sie denn dafür dass man sagt bei
den bei den asylbewerbern die hierher
kommt die die politisch verfolgt sind
die dürfen bleiben und die anderen
müssen tatsächlich dann über ein
qualifiziertes system hierher angeworben
werden wenn wir sie denn brauchen hier
als qualifizierte arbeitskräfte
ja wobei das thema fachkräftemangel ist
wieder ein weites feld das was immer so
postuliert wird sind oft forderungen der
wirtschaft um auch die das lohnniveau zu
drücken da muss man also sehr genau
hingucken
ich glaube wir haben
allein in der altersgruppe von 20 bis 35
jährigen in deutschland zwei millionen
junge menschen die keine
berufsausbildung haben wir sollten
vielleicht erst mal das eigene
fachkräfte reserve haben bevor wir an
anwerbung von sogenannter fach
einwanderung denken was ich jetzt gerade
gesagt haben zum thema in politik in
ihrer rede da haben sie doch einen
ziemlichen gegensatz zu jungen leuten
neben bundessprecher aufgebaut der ja
eher für eine wirtschafts oder otto
liberale richtung steht auch wenn er das
von sich gewiesen hat sie eher für eine
nicht nur national konservative sondern
stark sozial orientierte ausrichtung des
rentensystems sind sie der gegenspieler
von jörg merten in dieser
auseinandersetzung und wird sich
vielleicht möglicherweise an schärfe
noch zunehmenden der afd
ich denke die menschen im land wollen
dass wir intensiv diskutieren dass wir
hart diskutieren in der sache wir haben
genug konsensdemokratie in diesem lande
die menschen wollen wirklich
alternativen und wir machen jetzt auf
den weg
sozialpolitisch unsere pflöcke
einzuschlagen das wird eine lebhafte
diskussion werden ja davon bin ich
überzeugt aber ich schaue diese
diskussion nicht und jungen leuten hat
in seiner sehr guten rede heute deutlich
gemacht wie groß die spannbreite in der
afg es konservativ liberal liberale
soziale ansätze wir sind eine
volkspartei wir haben sind breit
aufgestellt und wir müssen jetzt einen
konsens finden wie gesagt das wird kein
einfacher weg das wird sicherlich auch
manchmal ein steiniger weg werden
aber ich bin optimistisch gerade wenn
ich die gute entwicklung
was die kooperationsfähigkeit der
führenden funktionäre in den letzten
monaten angucke dass wir zu einem guten
ergebnis kommen
die rente ist ja ein megathema da geht
es um menschliche existenzen eine
existenzielle frage muss man nicht ein
konsens hergestellt werden in der
gesellschaft
ja aber
die parteien die ja nun die seit
jahrzehnten dieses land gestalten haben
auf diesem politikfeld versagt ja wir
sind jetzt in einem stadium einer eines
eines kollabierenden rentensystems das
ja nur dadurch eingetreten ist das seit
jahrzehnten in diesem bereich nicht
ordentlich gearbeitet worden ist beginnt
von der schlimmen demografischen
entwicklung die ja nicht seit gestern
erst bekannt ist sondern seit anfang der
70er jahre haben in deutschland ein
sterbeüberschuss da hätte man mit einer
aktiven familienpolitik schon viel eher
deutliche zeichen setzen können das
haben die etablierten kräfte leider aus
welchen gründen auch immer nicht getan
da müssen wir an wir brauchen eine
aktive familienpolitik in deutschland
darf das ja zum kind auf gar keinen fall
von materialen erwägungen abhängen das
ist eine wichtige änderung die wir
vornehmen müssen und wie gesagt wir
müssen fokussieren was kann dieses land
leisten was kann dieses dieser
sozialstaat leisten wir dürfen uns nicht
überfordern wenn wir unseren sozialen
frieden gefährden indem wir unsere
sozialsysteme für jeden öffnen dann
spielen wir auch mit unserer
wirtschaftlichen leistungsfähigkeit und
verhindern auch dass wir in zukunft noch
humanitäre hilfe leisten können in aller
welt
das aktive familienpolitik sie wollen
also mit großen finanziellen einsatz
dass mehr kinder auf die welt kommen das
muss aber muss aber dann sehr viel geld
auch in die hand genommen werden dazu
sind wir bereit natürlich geht es nicht
nur materielle zuwendungen aber wenn
wenn wenn sie sehen dass für die
illegale einwanderung etwa 55 milliarden
euro jedes jahr ausgegeben werden dann
sage ich in aller deutlichkeit dieses
geld würde ich lieber unseren familien
zur verfügung stellen haben sie wirklich
das geld reicht um das umzukehren denn
die demografische entwicklung ist ja
eine entscheidung der bevölkerung das
ist ja nicht so sehr ein politisches
programm irgendeiner partei gewesen
also ich bin viel im land unterwegs und
unterhalte mich mit vielen vielen
menschen fast jeden tag und auch mit
vielen jungen menschen die kurz vor der
familiengründung stehen oder flächen ein
kind zur welt gebracht haben und die mir
sagen wir sind beide voll berufstätig
trotzdem reicht das geld vorne und
hinten nicht die lebenshaltungskosten
werden immer teurer
wir können keine zinsen wir kriegen
keine zinsen mehr auf unsere
spareinlagen wir würden gern noch ein
zweites oder drittes kind in die welt
setzen weil das für uns etwas
wunderbares und wertvoll ist es aber wir
können sonst schlichtweg nicht leisten
das ist ein unerträglicher zustand
diese umkehr dem demografische
entwicklung das bringen das menschliche
leben so mit sich das geht ja über einen
langen zeitraum mehrerer jahrzehnte was
passiert bis dorthin wir haben zum
bereich diesem bereich den sie
angesprochen und göttliche
pflegeversicherung eine älter werdende
gesellschaft massiver pflegekräftemangel
in deutschland wäre da eine möglichkeit
durch qualifizierte zuwanderung diesen
pflegekräftemangel in den nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahren auszugleichen denn er
muss ja jetzt behoben werden wir in
folge heimrecht mit der einschätzung
dass ein demografischer wandel
tatsächlich auch sehr lange braucht
bisher greift also ich meine jetzt den
positiven demografischen wandel noch mal
wir haben zwei millionen menschen
alterskohorte von 20 bis 35 ohne
abgeschlossene berufsausbildung lassen
sie uns bitte erstmal diese jungen
menschen in eine berufsausbildung
einmünden lassen sie uns diese menschen
in lohn und brot bringen eventuell auch
im pflegebereich dann haben wir ein
großteil des problems schon gelöst und
ja sie haben auch recht es geht nicht
nur materielle zu werden und bin selbst
vater von vier kinder und ich kann ihnen
sagen dass kinder das schönste sind auf
der welt dass kinder einfach eine
gesellschaft wahr machen wir brauchen
vor allen dingen auch eine mentale wende
im land wir brauchen weniger
konsumorientierung weniger egoismus und
wieder mehr die bereitschaft familien
sind auch zu leben haben sie sich aber
einiges vorgenommen mit dem letzten
vorhaben ja ich weiß wir müssen ein
dickes brett bohren aber dafür sind wir
angetreten
jan hoet landesvorsitzende stehen
thüringen im phoenix interview
danke dass sie hier waren so und wir
geben weiter zu claudias kröhnert